report any day now and that could have a
big impact on the future of the prime
minister meanwhile another battle is
apparently in full swing between number
10 and number 11 over what to do about
the cost of living crisis whether there
should be a windfall tax and what to
spend it on we'll find out what we can
with our guests this morning
so on the programme today we'll be
joined by the education secretary nadine
zahavi he'll be here in the studio with
us with labour focusing on the cost of
living we'll also be joined by the party
shadow chief secretary to the treasury
pat mcfadden this week i've been
speaking to the former health secretary
jeremy hunt about reducing avoidable
deaths in the nhs a windfall tax and
whether he'd fancy another crack at the
top job
we'll also be talking live to the
ukrainian mp lisa yasko to find out the
situation there and if there's any hope
for a negotiated end to the war
plus following a daring escape from
russia the [ __ ] riot activist lucy
stein is on the country's wanted list i
spoke to her as she takes refuge in
lithuania and raises money for ukrainian
refugees
[Music]
hello good morning so we're expecting
that report from sugray early next week
and it means the prime minister is going
to be facing more uncomfortable
questions about what happened at number
10 and the culture that he presided over
there of course also big questions over
the government's response to the cost of
living crisis with fresh measures from
the chancellor expected soon well i'm
pleased to say that this morning we are
joined by the education secretary nadine
sahar we thank you very much for being
on the program where there's lots to get
through education cost of living and but
i do just want to start with uh sue gray
and this meeting that was apparently
held between sue gray and between the
prime minister
who called that meeting
so two things to say on that one um i
don't know the details of all the
meetings that happen number ten but what
i do know
is that the prime minister has never
intervened in the investigation that sue
grey conducted
he has always wanted her to go wherever
the evidence takes her
i've worked with sue gray i've known sue
gray
i know she has the highest level of
professionalism
and her integrity
is unquestionable she didn't pull her
punches in her first report you remember
and then the pm came to parliament made
the changes in fact in number 10 because
the report was critical of the way
number 10 was operating and the price
made wholesale changes in number 10
and of course she will decide when to
publish her report
and the prime minister will respond to
that as well the important thing to
remember
in my view
is you know sue gray's been able to go
wherever the evidence takes her and will
decide
how she publishes what she publishes in
her report it's a really really simple
question
and obviously you're not going to be
across every single meeting in number
10. but this is a meeting that has been
in the press since sky news breaker on
friday night so it would be i think fair
of us to uh
assume that you will have asked a bit of
this to number 10 when you know that
you're going to go and be that
spokesperson this morning the reason i'm
asking who called the meeting is because
initially journalists were briefed that
it was sue gray her spokesperson then
had to come out and basically push back
on that so it wasn't true that she
didn't initiate this meeting so who did
call the meeting all i can say to you is
the meeting that took place between sue
great and the prime minister um i can't
tell you uh who called the meeting
because
i don't
because did you not ask the question of
number 10 before you came on this
morning or did they just not tell you
the answer no i i tell you what the
answer is the answer is very simple the
answer is the prime minister will never
intervene
in grey's
investigation the prime minister
wants sue grey to to basically go
wherever the evidence takes her and i
don't think ultimately who called the
meeting well
do you say you don't know about it
do you not know who called the meeting
because you didn't ask the question or
because number 10 didn't tell you the
answer no but if if sue grey decides
that um
when she publishes she decides you know
how she's going to
deliver her final report that's a
question that's a great question but no
but what i'm saying to you is
ultimately
there are two facts that your viewers
need to know one
the prime minister
does not
did not would never intervene in this
report he wants sue grey to publish her
report secondly
i've worked with sue gray i know sugree
sue gray's integrity is beyond question
so you're asking our viewers to accept
that the prime minister did not
intervene in this report right
absolutely right okay absolutely right
and i i just
just most of our viewers most of our
viewers would have more confidence in
that assertion if number 10 could be
straight with them about who called this
meeting and they are not being straight
who called the meeting well who was
saying
you know
that segue's first report didn't pull
its punches who called the meeting you
know that the prime minister
would never intervene in such a
investigation has not intervened has
allowed it to happen sue grace
you can't question segregate's integrity
because i've worked with superintendents
you're not questioning higher integrity
it's very very simple you will factor
you as i i one i don't know two i don't
know what's in the report right none of
us know what's in the report sue gray
will decide when to publish it and it
will be published that's the important
thing and then the prime minister will
respond to it you know we're we're
getting into there there are you know
meetings happen every day my diary is
full of music you can ask me a question
you know who put this this meeting in
your diary i literally come on your show
so i don't know but it went in the diary
because someone in my team would have
thought this is the right thing to do
right you're you're sort of creating
this
i'm absolutely nervous can i just get
out around this i'm not creating
anything out there the people who were
creating the air of doubt is number 10
because there is not a straight answer
to a very very straightforward question
who called the meeting that's literal
i don't want to have to keep asking the
same question i'm just sitting around
literally tens of meetings go into the
prime minister and the secretary of
state's diary you me we can have the
same conversation about a meeting that's
in my diary so how did that meeting get
in the direction i don't know because
that's the honest answer the honest
answer is that number 10 literally has
forgotten who arranged a meeting between
sue gray who was publishing an explosive
report potentially
into the prime minister and law breaking
number 10 and you were really asking us
to believe that number 10 they just
actually don't know how that meeting got
in the diary
i'm saying to you that what's important
what is material to your viewers is that
sue gray has conducted her report
independently the prime says never ever
intervened in her report that sue gray's
integrity and professionalism is beyond
doubt you just said to me you agree with
that that is what your viewers should be
concerned about i said i wasn't
questioning that i said i was asking but
you are you're saying you're saying you
call them no no you opened your question
just now by saying do you really expect
my viewers to have confidence right if
they can't if number 10 can't say who
actually uh put the meeting in the diary
i'm saying to you you can't doubt see
grace integrity or pressure you see me
of course i'm not doubting it but then
you go back to the same question
therefore you are casting doubt over it
so let's let's at least have an honest
conversation here about this i'm saying
to you
i don't know what's in the report no one
knows until sue gray decides to publish
it that's the right thing because
actually she's done this and done it
properly she hasn't pulled her punches
on the first report and she i'm certain
she won't be pulling her punches on
second because if i know sue grey she
will deliver that report independently
with respect i'm asking a very very
straightforward question about who
called a meeting between sugree and the
prime minister that's literal i'm asking
yeah and i've just said to you right i
don't know who called the meeting what i
do know is the prime minister doesn't
and never never would intervene in an
independent inquiry okay so grace
professionals beyond doubt meetings go
in my diary where if i come on here and
say to me how did this meeting get i
have to tell you the honest truth is i
don't know one of my officials would
have probably put it in the diary so
let's not sort of create this sort of um
air of doubt around some a process that
has been absolutely robust and rigorous
that's all i'm saying what was discussed
at the meeting
i don't know i've just said to you i
don't know but all i would say to you is
sue gray
knows that her
report has to be independent has to be
professional
and i'd that i have no doubt look at the
first report right she didn't pull her
on first you've said you've said
numerous times that the prime minister
didn't intervene
how do you know that if you don't know
what was discussed because because i
because i know the prime minister has
been determined from day one and he
shared with that with me with
um other ministers and of course the
country um that he would have sue grey
conductor report independently he would
never intervene or in any way try and um
influence that report and that is what
sue gray
has done and will publish and then the
prime minister will respond to it
afterwards i don't know what's in the
report right we will find out when it's
published what reason do you think the
prime minister could have for calling a
meeting or not or having a meeting i
should say we don't know who called it
for having a meeting with sue gray
before the report was published so
back to what i'm saying to you i if a
meeting's gone in the diary um for sue
gray and the prime minister meet i
guarantee you it's not because the prime
minister wants to influence the the
report um if sue great
you know meets the prime minister as
civil servants
if you don't know what the meeting was
about because it because i have no doubt
and of course
100
absolutely i've known see great i've
worked with see grey there is no way she
would allow herself to be influenced by
anybody do you have do you have faith in
the prime minister as well i do
influence that absolutely very much look
at the way he dealt with it in in her
first report
i'm sure you'd agree with me sue gray
did not pull her punches in the first
report what the primes did
do he didn't make any excuses he put his
hand up said we've got a problem we've
got to sort out number 10 and he went
forward and actually made the changes
number 10 brought steve barclay in to be
chief of staff brought david canzini
into the team made other changes andrew
griffiths came in to do policy big
changes in number 10 that are delivering
real outcomes for your viewers including
on national tutoring program which is on
the front page of one of the nationals
today 1.2 million blocks of tutoring for
children to make their recovery 6
million by the end of this parliament of
course the cost of living that we are
dealing with a global battle against
inflation 22 billion in the next 12
months that's helping people and the
chancellor's reviewing
what more we can do as we see
more of the data coming in on the global
battle against inflation which the us is
battling and the europeans are battling
a big agenda in this government 38 bills
in the queen's speech we're delivering
against that got a school's bill which
is going to mean every child will have a
great education wherever they live with
a great teacher in a classroom at the
right time in the right place for them
that's what we're focusing on let's um
talk about the cost of living twice the
same the sunday times reporting today
that rishi sunak is planning a windfall
tax on energy companies uh which could
mean that they get lower rates if they
increase investment is that something
that you would support so we will look
at all the options and i i with the
chancellor and the prime minister the
cabinet will look at every option let's
just think about your
the question of investment
so if you take what shel
are planning to do 25 billion pounds of
investment in renewables in green um bp
20 billion they both already paid double
the corporation tax the corporation tax
at 40
compared to what other sectors of the
economy pay um
there is it's not a a um zero cost
option why do i say that because uh if
you apply a windfall tax
they will probably have to reduce or
take away their dividend who receives
the dividend pensioners through their
pension funds right
investment
has to be
real which is what i think rishi will
demand of all these companies and to see
a road map towards that investment we're
not taking any options off the table the
important thing to remember is the 22
billion in the next 12 months is making
a difference so in april the 150 pounds
um uh
council tax rebate went to people's
accounts in october another 200 pounds
to bring down their uh electricity so
just to go back on the windfall tax
because it's quite interesting you know
in january you spoke about the windfall
tax saying that it's never going to cut
it but it feels like perhaps
if there are discounts available to
encourage investment
your position could change is that fair
sort of summary of where you're at so
i think as i said to you we have to be
very careful and very sort of clear-eyed
on this that there is no uh you know
zero cost options because
if you uh have a windfall tax um in the
way labour were proposing and i think
they were closing up 28 billion but if
there are but if there are perhaps uh
things that would encourage investment
you would be prepared to look at it a
bit more closely so we want to see their
investment but also just remember it's
pensioners who
basically get the dividend from these
companies and if they're going to cut
their dividend because they've had a
winful tax then that'll make a
difference to pensions as well so there
are no no
easy options here but the one thing we
are determined to do is be on people's
side talk on this on this um i just want
to read you part of the sunday times
story they say that downing street is
concerned that simply funding pain
relief handouts to households struggling
to pay bills will quickly be forgotten
by voters instead they want billions of
pounds diverted to long-term surgery
that will boost the economy for years to
come
it sounds a little bit this is obviously
from the sunday times but it sounds a
bit dismissive doesn't it
pain relief handouts because these are
people who perhaps wouldn't vote for the
conservatives anyway those pain relief
handouts could make a real difference to
people really struggling couldn't they
well first of all no one i have heard
speaks in this way
to
that report and sometimes so i don't
recognize that secondly uh what rishi
has done is to effectively deliver 22
billion in 12 months of help um if you
look at what we're doing
in july
there is a tax cut because we're raising
the national insurance threshold for 34
million people 34 million people will
get 330 pounds more per annum because of
that change what we've done for those
who are really struggling those on um
universal credit is the taper um
increase means they have an exercise the
rise in as you know the horizon
universal credit is far far below the
rise of inflation at a 40-year high it's
very difficult for the right family but
take the taper that's a thousand and
then on top of that the rise in the
national living wage is another thousand
that's two thousand pounds of help
that's gone in
local government councils know
which families i can tell you from my
own local authority that are really
struggling with the weekly shop with the
utility bills we've increased the amount
of help to a billion pounds and that
money getting out the door now but of
course rishi will keep looking at this
we will see more data coming through we
are in a global battle against inflation
you know that because you see it in
america you're seeing it in europe right
and
when
he
finds the best way to target the help to
those people who really need it he will
make an announcement i'm certain of it
and you think it will be before the
summer well as i said we keep an eye on
this and we're not complacent that's why
i worry about some of these reports
because i don't recognize this language
it sounds like people sort of talking
about this
in some somehow oh well
we might need to do something no we are
determined to be on people's side okay
um if the government is to increase
support you need to find savings uh some
pretty hefty cuts to the civil service
on the way is it true that you've
modelled cuts of up to 40 in your own
department so we're looking at
everything um in my um uh settlement is
that true about modelling cuts so we we
will look at all options the important
thing to remember so yes so hear me out
because it's important because
these are people's lives right i've got
great civil servants who are doing great
work in my department on my three
priorities on skills
t levels will be as famous as a levels
right on schools every child to be in a
great school wherever they live in the
country with a great teacher and on
families we're building family hubs in
half of england's local authorities
i need my people
to basically be focusing on my
priorities so the way we shape the
department i've got 8 000 people we're
going to drop to about 7 150 because
that's part of what we've done in the
spending review settlement it's about 11
to 12
decrease already but we'll look at where
else we can make savings across
government because actually
we are servicing a debt today the debt
servicing is 83 billion pounds a year
last year you used to be 20 billion this
is where you've got to ask labor who's
going to come on next which i will where
are they going to borrow financing
they're going to borrow another 28
billion right
labor uh later just just is the 40
figure accurate so we're we're looking
to model 10 percent we're above that
already 20 30 40 we will model across
that
the the thing to be aware of is you know
my focus
is to deliver outcomes what your viewers
want is by the end of this parliament
i've delivered a great school in every
constituency
for every child the right time the right
place for them i've delivered on the
skills agenda big skills agenda we're
going to stand behind every adult if
they want to retrain a reskill at any
time in their life with 37 000 pounds of
uh investment they can pull it off as a
whole or in modules in the lifelong
learning entitlement but what i'm saying
to you is i've got to shape my
department my people right to deliver
those things um i can't go to a place
where i i would actually impact delivery
that's my message to my team and of
course
to the nation ultimately now you gave a
uh interview to the times uh last week
that you said britain should be very
proud of its private schools and that
oxford and oxford and cambridge
admission should be based on merit and
evidence rather than tilting the system
away from children who are performing
so do you think there's a risk that the
system is being tilted away from private
school pupils so let me explain that
yeah what is merit if there are two
students one has gone to my
brilliant state schools and they're
getting better every day and one has
gone to an independent school they get
the same
set of results at a levels
then actually the university should take
the boy from the state school why
because he's had greater challenges to
overcome to get the same results what i
don't think you do you don't level up by
dragging people down our independent
sector you look at what king edwards
school foundation is doing in birmingham
where they actually run independent
schools and
uh state schools in one foundation what
eaton is planning to do with the star
academies um where they're going to
build three sixth form colleges in
places like oldham in westminster in the
areas that need that
investment in education i want to bring
everybody together right you you don't
succeed by delivering a great outcome
for every child by actually attacking a
part of the system i don't want to
attack independent schools they do a
great job they're joining us on this
journey more than school in oxford is
already looking at where they can
partner with their local authority and
former trust that's a great thing let's
celebrate that you're talking about
merit i guess the problem that some
people would argue is that because so
many private school pupils go to the top
universities that isn't on merit and
actually the landmark report the 2014
report
analyzing 132 000 students over three
years saying that state schools with the
same results much more likely to gain
two one or a first degree so a boy who
gets bbb at state school was just as
likely to get a 2-1 or a first as a
private school boy with abb so tilting
the system some would say actually that
is fair no i tell you what's fair is i
have to hold myself
and
my team and the front line to say
we can do as well right we can i've
already seen it i've evidenced it in my
white paper there are great families of
schools in high-performing multi-academy
trusts around the country i went to
catmo's trust in rutland the other day
right they delivered great results you
still sent your children to private
school though i i hear that was a that
was a parental decision i have to make
that with my wife i don't make that on
my own and i say to you we have great
independent schools they're joining us
on this journey to create real
improvement for all of our children but
the way you do that is by improving the
state system look at what um catherine
bill basing is doing with michaela she's
got a fantastic by the program tonight
on itv i know it's a different channel
but people should watch what catherine's
been able to do right look at catmo's um
uh multi academy trust look at dixon's
star academy um
the the brilliant phil harris in what
he's done with harris academies right
and smaller schools hammersmith academy
a single academy trust with gary
kiniston delivering great outcomes he's
got 60 people premium yet he stretches
every child to the best of their ability
and knows that there is no glass ceiling
you smash through it and you get to
oxbridge you get to wrestle group you
get to other universities or you do an
apprenticeship you do a t-level and a
degree apprenticeship we now are
building
many many runways for people's careers
to take off on not just the traditional
runway that's a good thing and
everyone's joining that journey
including independent schools let's
celebrate that just got one question to
you squeezing before i let you uh go i'm
not sure if you're aware of the story of
raheem bailey uh this is an 11 year old
boy who lost his finger when he was
fleeing from racist bullies allegedly he
was beaten kicked pushed to the ground
allegedly his finger was then amputated
after it was caught in a fence when he
was trying to run away
i just want to get your reaction to that
story and if we're doing enough to
tackle racist bullying
it's sickening
um
we always need to do more um
i suffered bullying when i first arrived
on these shores i couldn't speak english
and it was hard and you know i i
remember my my first experience at uh my
first school was holland park school
being chased around the park uh as a
sort of uh entertainment uh for bigger
boys and then throwing me in the pond
dunking me head down in the pond pretty
horrific for a child who just arrived on
these shores and you think that was a
racist element too well i don't know
it was a long time ago but i've
certainly
been
at the receiving end of other races uh
um
you know slurs words whatever
i was called the pacquiao school act
explained that they mean i'm from
pakistan i'm not from pakistan i'm
actually from a place called iraq and
i'm kurdish of origin it's called
kurdistan um
it's a horrible thing and i am
determined to stamp it out as i am
determined to stamp out anti-semitism in
our schools or in our universities
there's no place
for racism
anywhere in our society let alone in
education thank you for sharing your
personal story i'm sure that there'll be
lots of little boys and girls who will
find it quite you know inspiring to to
hear
someone overcoming that so thank you
very much
nadine zahawi they're the education
secretary
now inflation is at nine percent as we
were just uh discussing with our
previous uh guests it's a forty year
high and of course that is putting some
real pressure on family budgets labor
says that thank you to that rising
inflation the average family is almost
500 pounds worse off since the
chancellor's spring statement so what do
they intend to do about it let's try and
find out we're joined now by the shadow
chief secretary to the treasury pat
mcfadden thank you very much for being
with us uh this morning um so let's just
start off with that research shall we
you've been looking at the impact of
inflation on families and how concerned
are you
well we're very concerned this is the
biggest issue facing people right now
it's driven
in large part by the increase in energy
bills which is really driving inflation
up but we've also got inflation across
the board on food bills
other cost costs for industry and so on
and it's really really tough for
families out there now and people are
having to make some very very difficult
choices so what would labor do to tackle
inflation
well
you need a short-term plan and a
long-term plan and in the short term
we've got to get help to people
particularly with energy bills so we've
advocated
this policy of a windfall levy on the
excess profits of the oil and gas
companies who are making the most out of
the current energy price inflation
and together with other measures using
that to get more help
to people with energy bills
particularly those
at the lower end of the income scale who
spend a greater proportion of their
income on energy than better off
families and what's a long-term plan the
long-term plan is we've got to improve
the country's economic growth record
we're in this spiral of
difficult choices around tax and spend
because we've had poor economic growth
for 10 or 12 years now so we've got to
get our growth record up in the future
in order to make the country more
prosperous and the people living in it
more prosperous let me explain that what
that
do you do that i mean like
better growth is sounds great doesn't it
i think everyone would agree with that
but but how do you do well you need you
need a number of things uh first of all
we've got to you were talking to nadeem
zahawi about skill levels for example
we've still got 200 000 children
living in areas where there are no good
or outstanding schools the government's
actually having a debate with themselves
about sending not enough people i guess
they're sending too many people to
university at the same time like you
know you've got to get i've asked about
the question was how would labour tackle
inflation the windfall tax obviously is
something that we've talked about uh
every interview i talk about uh labour
front benches it's windfall tax but then
leaping towards schools as a way of
tackling inflation
it's a contributor to long-term growth
the skills of your people also for
example the green transition that we've
got to make
that can be a contributor to
long-term economic growth if we get it
right we match the technology the
capacity to make things here you need a
short-term plan at the moment to help
people with a cost of living crisis and
you need a long-term plan geared at the
country's prosperity um i guess i'm um
you know trying to work out a bit more
about the policy platform that labour
has i understand the windfall tax and
it's something that clearly you know you
can see government thinking about as
well um but it does feel like every time
i talk to labour all you talk about is
the windfall tax and the crisis is real
as you say you know inflation at a
40-year high you want an emergency
budget you need something else in it
other than
let me give you another example if you
take costs for business which are a real
part of this right now we've advocated
more help for business rate relief paid
for by increasing the digital services
tax for this year
in order to get business rate relief to
a greater range of businesses that could
take
up to 5 700 pounds of business rate
bills for some small and medium-sized
businesses because inflation yes it's
about consumers but it's also about cost
for business too so that's another plank
of our policy platform alongside the
windfall levy um just talking about um
how you pay for the policy platform as
well so the windfall tax rate is around
two billion pounds a year on the sort of
latest figures you also want to you know
spend 28 billion pounds a year on the
sort of green plans tackling climate
change you want to increase defense
spending you know you've spoken out
against the rise in national insurance
how are you going to pay for all this
would labor be put on up borrowing well
let me take the green plan that you just
quoted look at the scale of what we've
got to do over the next 10 or 20 years
there are 30 million cars on the road
i'm not asking about the right or wrong
of the policy i'm asking about how it'll
be paid for it will be paid for by more
borrowing wouldn't it uh that that is a
borrowing plan it's borrowing for
investment and the government's already
doing it at a time of rising inflatables
the government has already issued 16
billion pounds of green gilts for
precisely this purpose
governments in poland germany france all
issuing green gills that is our policy
to
borrow in the markets to invest in this
transition and if we don't do that if we
abandoned green gilts for example say
we're not going to do any of that what
we'd be doing is leaving greater cost to
the next generation because the longer
you leave this transition the more
expensive it will be and also it will be
unfair to consumers if you take these
heat pumps right now for example cost a
lot more than a gas boiler for my
constitution for my constituents
this transition has to be fair it can't
just be a transition for the rich so
this requires a partnership between
government and industry to make sure
that britain make gets the best
advantage of it and also to make sure
it's done in a fair way have you
modelled the cost of the rising interest
rates on this
look we always have an eye on everything
but green guilts are already part of the
policy mix we want to use them to make
sure we get this transition done in a
fair way okay okay um now i just want to
have a look at a piece that you wrote
for the times uh back in march 2020. now
this was at the time the leadership
contest uh to replace jeremy corbyn and
this is what you said if it's quote uh
okay that is not the quote i was hoping
for so the quote says after labour lost
its third election in a row in 1987 neil
kinnick launched a no holds barred
policy review in which everything was on
the table including the sacred cows such
as support for unilateral nuclear
disarmament he did that because he knew
that fundamental change was necessary if
labour was to win again and then he went
on to say after a shattering defeat the
key question is direction it means
having a policy platform that looks to
the future
i just wonder if you feel like that you
know genuine no holds barred policy
review has happened under kirstalma
well i've always been clear that
leadership wasn't just about a change of
personnel it had to be a change of
direction to
when you lost four elections in a row
uh you can't just go back with the same
policy platform and
uh a person in a different suit and
expect the electorate to
to take a different attitude so i'm very
much in favor of root and branch
examination of things but if you take
the group that's happening if you touch
to take the example we've been
discussing this morning on the green
agenda there i think you've got an
ambitious program
for a transition that's going to happen
anyway but i want us to be hungry for
change in every area in education policy
in health policy learning the lessons of
the covert experience what can we do
better in the future being radical
enough in providing that opposition
we will only know the answer to that
when we come to the next election but i
think there is a hunger for change in
the labour party now it feels like you'd
like to go a bit further we've always
got further to go because when you've
had such an emphatic defeat
as the one that we had in 2019
uh the worst thing you could do is to
think one more heave was going to do it
for you one more heave won't do it for
us we've got a new leader but we also
need a new direction too interesting and
you don't think that new direction has
come yet well we're it's a we're part of
the way through and we've got you know
some time to go before the next election
but i'm confident that we'll have an
exciting and responsible program when it
comes to that
um we spoke uh to nadim zahawi uh
earlier about the meeting between sea
gray and boris johnson he couldn't tell
us who called that meeting
are you concerned about the fact that
sue grey the civil servant leading the
investigation into particular met with
the prime minister
i've got every faith in sugree's
integrity she is a civil servant of the
highest integrity we don't know the
details of that meeting
uh
it's not clear who called it there's
different accounts of that so it's hard
for me to say what was said there um but
i do have faith in her integrity and
let's see what she says when the report
comes out
okay i mean it does feel after the met
have concluded their investigation no
more fines boris johnson
that actually the person who's come out
of this with their future more uncertain
is actually kiss dama because he said of
course that he will resign if he's found
to breach the law with the investigation
that's going on by uh durham police
given the unpredictability of these
fines was that gamble really such a
great idea
look i think the statement he made the
other week
showed real integrity and leadership
he's the former director of public
prosecutions he takes adherence to the
law extremely seriously
and if you contrast that to the culture
that's been exposed both by what the
mets uncovered and by what we're likely
to see in sue gray's
report you see that culture comes from
the top isn't this almost
you know the point
why is kirsten put his future on the
line in a way that he perhaps didn't
need to
kirsten
holds public service and the standards
of public service extremely highly
you know he doesn't believe this notion
that well they're all the same no
scandal matters no shame matters you can
get away with anything there's a real
contrast
in standards between what he's said and
the way he's conducting himself through
this remember he also this is someone
who isolated four or five times i think
when having covered our family members
have he's taken adherence to the rules
extremely seriously okay and he's
contrasting that with a culture that's
been exposed in number 10.
okay um it it feels like it has um
sparked a bit of an informal leadership
contest though doesn't it um you know
we've got
pages like the front financial times
doing interviews with uh word streeting
framing them about whether or not he's
the savior of the labour party uh is
where street in the savior labour
desperately needs lisa nandy and bridget
phillips and haven't rolled ruled out a
run when they've done interviews i mean
this is not helpful is it
well look uh i'm very confident in kyo
stammer's leadership
but it's also really encouraging for me
to see so many other talented people in
the labour party their time is not yet
maybe it will be one day in the future
okay thank you uh very much uh pat
mcfadden there from the labour party
well from domestic politics we can turn
to ukraine now because president
zielinski says only a negotiated
settlement can end the war in his
country the final standard mario poll
seems to have been defeated and russian
forces have intensified their attacks in
the south and east of ukraine
meanwhile the u.s has authorized 40
billion dollars of aid to ukraine half
of it to military supplies as the war
looks to continue for some time yet
we can hear from ukraine now and speak
to the ukrainian mp lisa yasko thank you
so much for being with us uh today and
can you just explain to us what the
situation on the ground is like where
you
are good morning well i'm currently
traveling to the was world economic
forum
but the situation in ukraine is
still very sad it's already three months
of the war and people are very desperate
the fighting mood is still very very
high but the traumas and traumatized
situations that we all got from all of
that are only increasing
many people lost their jobs uh the
economic situation is very hard of
course many lost their
relatives their friends
and it's going on and
the news that we hear today that russia
for example is using two-thirds of its
military submarines right now with the
with the rackets
they are right now in in the sea is very
warning and uh
it's very sad that we all got used to
the fact that there are sirenas and the
warnings the air air warnings every day
and many people
see their normal life
as as
with this sounds but it's not normal and
we need to change that
we've um seen a situation where the
russians have finally taken mario paul
after that extraordinary defense that
was waged there including at the steel
works but now of course it means they
can really focus their attention on the
east and in the donbass region how is
the fighting there
it's very harsh
and tough
for many people it's very hard to get
any connection with their
sons with their brothers or their
husbands who are fighting there right
now in our military there is almost no
connection still there is
like thousands of people who are under
attack on everyday basis without food
without water
many are
taken forcefully to russia
we know that the forest migration is
taking place and the children are
kidnapped
women are raped
unfortunately situation didn't become
better and
it actually got worse because now we
know more about the numbers
so now we understand that
it's a matter of of our
persistence and our fighting mood and
there is no way back we need to win it
all we need to
have peace there and it we need to have
our territories back and we need your
help i mean the help of the
international
community of course to make it happen
that's interesting just to uh clarify
then the ukrainian position still that
there'll be no territory given up to
russia
we're not going to give any territory to
russia that there cannot be any
compromise on that especially with that
thousands of numbers of victims that we
currently have of civilians and and the
military
uh and our army we're not going to
forgive this and uh it's not even in in
the discussion
okay okay and what what is the status of
crimea in that discussion
well we
we believe that we can bring crimea back
and our victory will only depend when
all our territories will be back because
now putin is uh completely in a crazy
uh
mood and we understand that he is using
all his force to
destroy ukraine and for us it's a very
existential question we need to have our
territories back because we already paid
very high price for it and we will go
till the end to have our territories
back
do you think this is a war that you can
win given the size of the russian
military
well i think
in the world it's very hard to win
because there are always victims and
something that you lose and it's very
painful and that's something that will
remember for
maybe like hundreds of years in in the
future
uh but of course talking about our
freedom
and our peace in our territory there is
no other way just the victory because we
are not going to be slaves
it's not
acceptable for us
we are very freedom loving nation and we
will go till the end still the full
victory with this
wow and what help do you need from the
international community you spoke a
little bit earlier in the interview
about needing more well of course it's
about military assistance and it's about
economic assistance right now and we
need more and more sanctions on russia
to isolate russia so that russia gets
less money to finance its work crimes in
in ukraine and uh we need it very very
quickly
because as we see three months have
already passed and we could stop it much
earlier but russia still has resources
to have war in ukraine we need to do
everything possible to make sure that
russia doesn't have resources for that
anymore
are you talking about those resources
and of course a lot of them come from
the sale of oil and gas particularly to
countries in europe don't they
exactly and it's very sad when we still
have some dialects with some european
countries discussing uh oil and gas
embargo while we are losing lives of
people every day and someone is scared
to lose
some money from that but we are sure
that the business is usually is not
acceptable anymore the world is
different right now and it's a matter of
time only when we will have the new
reality and one more thing that is very
important we need to change the
international order i'm now talking
about the international organizations
and the tools that we may have to stop
the war and to have peace in the future
united nations council of europe other
organizations they need to have real
tools not just on paper but real tools
that will ensure that we will not have
work in ukraine or in other european
countries
in the future anymore
now women and girls are so often you
know the victims of war and we've
certainly seen that in ukraine and if
i'm being honest you know the some of
the stories
about you know the rape and the
treatment of children as well coming out
of your country have been some of the
hardest that i've ever covered as a
journalist with no doubt it's very
tempting to look the other way but it
does feel like we have to bear witness
can you share any of the individual
stories that you've heard
since this war just to give our viewers
a bit of a sense of what is happening
well one of my colleagues lost her
husband and they have two children
he was killed
i also know people who are in kiev
obviously who were living in cave of
blessed who were raped and currently are
pregnant or uh
with very strong psychological traumas
but the numbers of these people are
thousands and i know that the hotline uh
receives like lots of calls
every day from people who are in need
but even those who didn't suffer so much
we all need that because life for us is
completely different for me for example
it's very hard to have
any happy moments because every every
second i know that there is a war in my
country and i cannot afford having any
positive moments but what's to do with
those who for example were raped in
front of the
eyes of their children or
they lost their children and we know
that there is a real nightmare of that
were crimes that were happening because
the rapes were happening not only to
women but also to children and to
elderly and simultaneously and i have no
idea who are those people who were
raised this way who were thinking that
raping
this way
so wide scale widespread is normal can
you imagine what is happening in the
brain of these people and it's a
big big tragedy and big question that i
believe we need to address as
international community how did it
happen there are so many people
in russia in russian society who think
that using violence is okay
it's a great danger
it's absolutely unbelievable as you say
um
you mentioned there about knowing people
who are pregnant after rape
how concerned are you that poland has
got such restrictive abortion laws when
obviously so many millions of ukrainian
women are going to poland
yeah unfortunately it's a big problem
because we know that abortion is banned
in poland and it's an additional
big problem for ukrainian women but i
know that there is assistance provided
also from other countries and it's it's
a process it's not going that smoothly
but i i know that there is lots of
assistance that is on the way and is
provided to people who are in in need
including this kind of assistance
and with the need of medical care and
those who are
unfortunately suffering from from rape
but it needs time it cannot be fixed in
one day and it's incredibly dramatic and
sad for all of us
thank you so much for talking so
powerfully to us and this morning it's
such a privilege to get to speak to
people like you and also
you know you said that you can't feel
happy anymore and i really hope that you
know in the future that does change
thank you
always some of the most powerful
interviews that we do on this program
coming out of ukraine
now our next interview is the longest
serving health secretary or he was when
he handed over to matt hancock in 2018
that's around 16 months before covert
hit
and when jeremy hunt stepped down from
front bench politics he said he wanted
to do for patient safety what al gore
did for climate change in a new book
he's called for fundamental culture
change in the nhs to prevent avoidable
deaths
and with questions over boris johnson's
future he's never ruled out another run
for the concept of leadership either
let's have a little listen to what
happened when we spoke to jeremy hunt
earlier this week i started by asking
about the nhs
well i think it can be a rogue system
from the point of view of families when
something goes wrong and sometimes they
feel the shutters come down and no one
wants to meet them and
explain why a loved one's died
but i also think it's important to say
that the vast majority of nhs care is
absolutely brilliant i've got three
lovely children all born on the nhs he
mended my elbow last year when i broke
it brilliant surgeon and physio
but the question is when things do go
wrong as they do in all health systems
how good are we at learning from
mistakes and what i found writing this
book is that the one thing the families
want when something goes wrong it's
never money it's just to feel that the
loss of their loved one has some meaning
because the system's learnt from what
what went wrong and
isn't going to make the same mistake
again and i guess that's the critical
point isn't it um not making the same
mistake again do you feel that the
shutters coming down as you say it has
effectively led to more avoidable deaths
yes and
when i was writing this book i came to
realize this is not just a problem in
the nhs it's a problem in healthcare
systems all over the world
but if you think about the most
traumatic thing that could happen in a
hospital which is perhaps a baby dying
that is equally traumatic for the
doctors and nurses and midwives
as it is for the family
and they have to come into work the next
day and and carry on looking after other
patients and they want to do nothing
more than be open and transparent and
learn the lessons
the system can make that impossible they
are worried frankly they'll get fired if
they are open about having made a
mistake but then they are thinking about
you know what are their bosses in the
nhs going to do the regulators what are
they going to say are they going to get
struck off the register
and
the result of that is that the one thing
that matters more than anything else
which is that lessons are learned
is the thing that often doesn't happen
because of this terrible blame culture
um i mean you speak a little bit as if
you
weren't health secretary i mean you were
the longest-serving health secretary a
lot of people people would be thinking
why haven't you done something about it
well i try to be honest in this book
about where i did make progress and
where i failed to make progress
i think in terms of transparency and
openness we are in a better place
three million more patients were using
good or outstanding hospitals by the end
of my time compared to when i started
but there were also things i didn't fix
i didn't put in place a long-term plan
for the social care system and
you know when you hear stories as we've
been hearing this week about people
waiting an hour for an ambulance when
they have a stroke
a lot of the reason for that is because
hospitals can't discharge people into
the social care system and they get full
and so
there were things that i wish i had made
more progress on do you think boris
johnson should be making more progress
on social care as well i mean i remember
it's one of the things that he obviously
spoke about when he first became prime
minister and yet it doesn't feel like
much has happened
yes i think he has made some progress
the cap on care cost is being introduced
and that will be a big relief to
people who have
neurological conditions like dementia
but the core funding for local
authorities is still not where it needs
to be you know one of the stories that i
found most shocking recently is the
shrewsbury telford trust which the
report of course found
that more than 200 babies and nine
mothers died
unnecessarily because of failings in
that trust catastrophic failures in that
trust we also know of course that women
who aren't white are five times more
likely to die during pregnancy
is the maternity care system in the uk
fit for purpose
the vast majority of births are totally
safe but we can do better if we had the
same maternity safety rates of sweden a
thousand more babies would live every
year in england and why what's going
wrong is it funding for midwives what
what is it is it attitudes well my
select committee did a report into this
last year
and donna ockendon did a report into
shrewsbury and helford
more recently and we both said the same
thing which is number one we need more
midwives and more doctors at least 2 000
more midwives at least 500 more doctors
and nurses and
other people
the government's accepted that
recommendation
the second thing though is have you seen
any progress on that or they just said
that they accept it
not yet what we've heard is the
government accepting the recommendation
but they haven't said when they will
recruit those extra midwives how long
ago was it that you scored for it then
we called for it last summer and
nothing's happened and we need to make
progress urgently because we need
every mum to know that
if they are going into a maternity unit
there isn't going to be a shortage of
midwives or doctors so it is absolutely
essential to act quickly do you think
that if men gave birth a system would
work better
it's a good question um i think there
are
blind spots when it comes to women's
illnesses talking about women's health
um there have been reports of coming
from the u.s that roe vs wade will be
overturned now you've personally said
before that you think the abortion limit
should be reduced to 12 weeks although
you have said that it's not a law that
you would introduce if you would be
prime minister it's just a personal
opinion of yours
what's your reaction to roe vs waves
well i'm totally against it let me
be clear i'm a supporter of the system
in holland
which has
no restrictions on early stage abortions
and then they get progressively
higher as the pregnancy continues so
that's the system that i
but it's a personal view and i
it's a matter of a free vote and i
always said in government positions this
is not something for me to
pursue i'd be extremely worried if in
the united states
we ended up with a situation where women
couldn't access
basic health rights
there's obviously been a huge pressure
on the nhs recently through covert
staff absences treatments being delayed
if there is a spike in cases in the
winter are you worried about the
preparedness of the nhs
i'm always worried about the capacity of
the nhs if there was one thing that i
wish i'd known at the start of my quite
a long time as health secretary it is
that you can't solve problems with money
alone money matters but there is a big
and legitimate debate about funding for
the nhs and care system
but you can't put three billion pounds
into the system and expect to see change
unless there are three billion pounds
worth of extra doctors and nurses and
beds to use for many families things are
really really difficult the government
talks about the support that it's
already put in
but do you feel
that more needs to be done to help those
particularly on the lowest incomes
i think the government is doing a lot i
mean the sums of money in terms of
billions of pounds which of course come
from taxpayers ultimately are huge but
the core problem
is that inflation is at record levels
and that is just eating away at family
finances and and we heard the figures
this week that the inflation rate is
even higher for the poorest families so
i think the heart of the issue is how do
we bring down the inflation rate
personally i'd be very attracted to
things that reduce people's fuel bills
because that helps people on low incomes
but also brings down the inflation rate
and some of your colleagues have talked
about um help on universal credit and
obviously there was a 20 uplift during
the pandemic is that the kind of thing
you'd like to see targeted at the people
on lower incomes i wouldn't like to
second-guess the chance on the precise
measures but i do think targeting help
is the most important thing do you like
the idea of a windfall tax
i
let me say this i'm pleased that the
chancellor has said all options are on
the table
because i find it very difficult to
justify
bp
buying back two and a half billion
pounds of shares because of a hike in
the oil price do you think it's
inevitable that the government's going
to u-turn on this
i think that we are hearing signs that
all options are on the table and so we
need to watch this space it feels like
it's something that you
would be quite attracted to
personally i find it very difficult to
justify those those extra profits
and the met police have concluded their
investigation into partygate 126 fines
for eight gatherings
should boris johnson have done the same
as kier stameron to pledge to resign if
he's found guilty of a criminal offence
i wouldn't want to minimize uh the anger
people feel about the fact that people
in downing street did not follow the
rules that they set for other people
but i think
that the anger that the electorate feel
the way that my party suffered in the
local elections is about more than that
i think the
fundamental
problems in the economy high inflation
low growth are something that are
worrying a lot of families
i don't think the next election will be
about partygate i think it will be
fought on which party has the best
long-term plans for the economy for the
nhs where i hope my book will make a
contribution at the same time they know
i've spoken to conservative mps who said
that party gate came up an awful lot on
the doorstep at those local elections
because i guess it's about
what people feel is the character of the
prime minister as well
i think there are some voters who were
extremely angry and there were some
conservative voters who were extremely
angry
but i think those same voters also
look at the situation uh in the world
look at what's happening in ukraine
and see that what's going wrong there is
of a scale with a totally different
magnitude
i personally don't believe we should
have a change in prime minister right
now britain has been the most robust
member of the western alliance
and i think the only person who would be
pleased if we had a
hiatus of several months in the
leadership of the uk would be vladimir
putin that doesn't mean to say that i
don't recognize the anger that a lot of
people feel um do you think there's been
a bit of a complacency
after the local election results because
they were pretty bad for your party
particularly in the south
let me put it this way i think it would
be wrong to say this is just midterm
blues i think the core reasons that
people vote conservative which is
uh the prospect of strong economic
growth the prospect of lower taxes
these things are not true at the moment
and people are really worried about the
the inflation level the the very low
growth rates i'm worried about it
because i want us to be able to fund the
nhs spend more on defense and offer the
prospect of lower taxes and the only way
you can do all those things is by
getting growth into the economy
i'm not going to ask the um
the typical if the ball came loose at
the back of the scrum question because
frankly we actually do know the answer
to it you know you haven't ruled out
another
crack at the leadership and you said
earlier this year that your ambition
hasn't completely vanished
why do you think you would be good at
the top job
it's a very good way of asking the same
question sophie um so full marks for
trying um my i've been very honest that
um i don't rule back a return to
frontline politics my ambition has ebbed
somewhat since stepping back because
i've loved uh being with my family i
know it's a terrible cliche when
politicians say that but it is actually
true in my case it's not disappeared
it hasn't disappeared but i don't think
now is the moment for a change in prime
minister
for the reason i mentioned i think
something that makes vladimir putin
happy is precisely what we don't want
at this moment when we have the first
european war
in our lifetimes the risk of chemical
and biological and even nuclear weapons
being used
the reports that you send back from
places like mario paul i think do
give us a perspective and britain's role
in the western alliance contrary to what
many people thought has been extremely
important very robust and it's what we
need to see now okay thank you very much
thank you
jeremy hunt there there'll be lots more
about the state of play here in
westminster on our midweek programme
that's the take with sophie ridge so you
get more from me that's uh every
wednesday evening at 9 00 p.m it's a
chance for us to take the political
temperature at midweek some interviews a
bit of reacting to prime minister's
questions
as well and we'll also
be talking to our viewers panel just to
try and get a bit of a sense of how the
public is reacting to the biggest
political stories of the week so yeah
lots of fun the take that is wednesday's
9pm uh do join us there on sky news
you're watching security on sunday after
the break we will be watching my
interview with lucy stein of putty riot
you don't want to miss that one
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
organized
[Music]
so
[Music]
hello welcome back to sophie bridge on
sunday
now in late march the [ __ ] riot
activist lucy stein put on a bright
green food delivery uniform and she
slipped out of her small moscow flat
she'd been under house arrest there for
more than a year as a long-time critic
of the putin regime that she'd been
detained for a protest calling for
opposition leader alexa navalny's
release now her girlfriend and fellow
activists escaped similar charges and
the country and the pair are now
reunited and performing in europe to
raise funds for ukrainian refugees i
spoke to her about her nerve-wracking
journey and a very special traveling
companion
you escaped from moscow in march after
being under house arrest for over a year
can you just explain why you were under
house arrest
i were under house arrest for the
criminal case
it was like
about
so-called breaking college rules
but actually it was because of the
protest rally
we participated to subvert alexina wiley
who was
[Music]
imprisoned
after poison he was poisoned
so
um
it was a
criminal case for
10 people we were sent
under house arrest for
like half of a year
and
after it we were sentenced for
the restriction of freedom it is uh
uh it's uh also like a house arrest so
very difficult conditions to be living
under and how did you
manage to escape
firstly it was a complete house arrest
when i wasn't able to leave home anytime
but
then uh it was like
only a restriction for night
to live for apartments so i had a day
time and
i left uh house like in the morning and
when they
found out that
i'm not
there at my place i already
was
too far
and you wore a disguise
i had to wear this
suit
food delivery costume
and
so when i realized that i have to escape
from russia i
just
used this costume again
and how did you manage to get from
russia to lithuania which is where you
are now it was it were three cars um
first car in russia then second car to
belarus and a
third car
uh to lithuania actually but um
i'm not sure that
uh it's a good idea to talk about this
um
method a lot because i'm not the last
person who have to
leave russia
this way
yeah that makes a lot of sense and
you're saying you're not the only person
of course who's had to leave russia i
think your girlfriend has also managed
to escape
yeah she did she did the same thing
after me
and so lucy you escaped russia with
somebody who did you escape with
mr rat
hey
how did how did you escape with him
i put him in
my
delivery food back
and
he was staying there
uh during this trip
and how was he during the trip was he
okay
yeah he's uh he's a strong red i i think
he
understood that we have to leave
our home
and why did you just scarce decide to
make your escape in march was that
because the situation had got more
dangerous after the invasion of ukraine
first of all i realized that um if i
if before i wanted to
wait for the end of my sentence and
be able to leave russia legally and to
come back to russia legally
um i changed my mind um
[Music]
after the invasion to ukraine because
i
understood that i
don't want to live there anymore even
if uh
they
would leave me alone
and no
jails no arrest no prosecution
um
even
if i
would be a free person in russia i just
don't want to
[Music]
stay there anymore if you're staying
there
or not even there you just can't be
silenced about what's happening and if
you can't um
and if you call
the war the war
it's also forbidden
um
you are
risking like to be in prison for 15
years
so if you criticize the war in ukraine
you could go to prison for 15 years now
that's that's the situation
even if you're just calling the war the
war because uh our government uh
calls it uh like special operation i
think some people in the west don't
understand why more people in russia
aren't protesting about ukraine or
aren't speaking out do you think that's
because people support the war or
because people are too afraid about what
would happen if they did speak out
if russian people
would
know the truth they won't
support the war but um
not all of them but
i think a big part
of them are just
watching tv propaganda and
they don't know what's uh actually
happening there and they think that
uh ukrainians are analysis and uh
russian soldiers um
are
peacemakers
is it like being brainwashed
yeah yeah brainwashed
yeah good word
you're 25 years old
you've been under house arrest for a
year
you had to flee your home
these are really big big sacrifices for
someone your age you could have lived a
much much easier life
why did you feel you had to do it
if you live in russia you have
to watch every
day
what's happening and uh
you just feel uh bad if you are uh
silenced and uh
it's uh
it's kind of uh it's for for me it's uh
this way um
i just
couldn't
ignore it even then you had to speak out
yeah
and my mom
yelled at me because
star started
can you wait like
several days
escape and
post anything you want but i
couldn't and it's even dangerous to like
to make a repost about
um
about war criminal
and
about what happened in bulgaria for
example thank you so much honestly it's
been great to talk to you we really
appreciate it thank you
thank you
i knew she's standing there and i guess
her mum at least will be pleased that
she's doing that interview
after escaping russia making it to
lithuania well after the break we're
going to be turning our attention to
northern ireland we'll be speaking live
to naomi long the leader of the alliance
party
[Music]
i'm hannah thomas peter and i'm skye's
climate change correspondent
the uk is a world leader in wind power
it's part of the congo basin rainforest
which is such an important ecosystem
it's known as the lungs of africa
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
she doesn't really enjoy speaking to the
press and it wasn't clear right up until
the last moment that she was going to
sit down with me i might be just very
naive but i do believe that change is
possible otherwise we wouldn't be
climate activists
[Music]
i'm confident for the last 30 years
we have known how bad it is i'm not here
to apologize i'm here to fight for the
next step
you can see just the piles and piles of
stuff these this sofas and people's
desks and children's books and you can
see inside this home here people trying
to
to sort out their home it's just been
devastating
i think everything's at stake the future
of our planet the future of the beauty
around us
the future
of you and me
it was everything that a journalist
might want in a story a story that you'd
be proud to have filmed
that they didn't want journalists to see
the real story
it was very tiring it was very sad it
was very scary at times there's no need
for this but you have to keep going
look at that
you don't want to lecture people but you
do have to give them a fact
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
the inspiration behind our product came
from
understanding how big of a problem
livestock meat and emissions were
hello welcome back to safety ridge on
sunday now shinfam made history recently
uh when taking
the most votes and the most seats in
northern ireland's elections but the
assembly is still deadlocked as the dup
demands changes to the protocol and the
uk government routes with the european
union but the non-sectarian alliance
party was one of the biggest winners too
they more than doubled their seats with
a big jump in votes especially among
young people possibly pointing to a
different future for northern irish
politics
well the party says the assembly must
restart and they want to overhaul the
entire power sharing system
so let's speak now to the alliance
leader naomi long who is live in belfast
for us this morning thank you very much
for being with us um you did very well
in the recent assembly elections and i
just want to start by talking a little
bit about what the alliance party stands
for uh what is it that you're about and
what in particular is your stance on the
good friday agreement
well thank you sophie and we have been
perfect supporters of the good friday
agreement because from our inception 51
years ago we were committed to power
sharing and evolution locally as the
best way to provide a stable future for
the people of northern ireland to allow
people to self-govern um and to create a
society which was egalitarian unfair
because that was not the case prior to
that point and unfortunately it's still
not the case now
alliance would describe itself um as a
liberal and progressive party but also
we are a pragmatic party and very keen
um to be able to continue to work to
deliver improvements for people's lives
which is why the assembly is so
important
at the same time you want to see
non-sectarian
power sharing which feels like it could
be quite ambitious do you think it is
really achievable
well i think the alternative is the stop
go assembly that we have seen over the
last five years where for the majority
of the time we haven't had functioning
devolution i don't believe that's
sustainable people in northern ireland
are facing a cost of living crisis
they're concerned about the state of our
health service which is some of the
longest waiting lists in the uk and what
they want is government to deliver
change and to try to assist them with
those issues and instead what they get
is government which is held around some
sometimes by shin fan sometimes by the
dup and the cycle of crisis and collapse
and the only way we can stop that
happening is to remove
the vetoes that those parties currently
are able to exercise over the
institutions and allow all votes in the
assembly to account for the same amount
because currently my vote doesn't count
for the same amount as other colleagues
because i won't designate as unionist or
nationalist and so we need to deal with
this fundamental issue the good friday
agreement provided us with a means of
managing division in northern ireland
but society has changed as the good
friday agreement intended it would in
the last 24 years and so we now need to
be open to changing the mechanisms and
structures not the principles of par
sharing not the idea that we have to
share this place together and work
together in order to deliver but
actually the mechanisms that are there
which currently are making the
institutions more unstable and that's
what we would like to see happen in
order that when we come to these
difficult issues whether it's the
protocol or or whether it's something
else because there is always something
else that we're able to work through
that rather than stop government until
it's resolved
you're talking about the sort of
stop-start nature of government and
shinoba and the dep being able to hold
northern ireland to ransom
do you think that is what the dep is
currently doing then holding northern
ireland to ransom by refusing to enter
power sharing because of their concerns
over the protocol or do you have a bit
more sympathy with their position
well i understand their position i
understand their lack of trust in the uk
government because i think at times the
uk government have used northern ireland
as
a bit of a play thing when it comes to
maintaining a grievance with europe they
believe that for them electorally for
the conservatives in england this is a
positive and so they're willing to
continue to have this constant grievance
with the european union and northern
ireland is i suppose a useful lever for
them but it's very damaging for
community relations and for good
governance in northern ireland and so i
do understand why the dup um lack trust
and promises made by the uk government
but undoubtedly they're holding the
people of northern ireland to ransom i
mean jeffrey donaldson himself has said
that he is using the position of being
able to prevent government as leverage
over the uk government so i mean there's
no question about that and they've been
openly admitting it my problem is that
it also holds the rest of us to ransom
who want to get back to work who want to
start delivering for the people who
elected us only two weeks ago and who
believe that there are parts that we
have within the assembly that can
address the very immediate problems of
fuel costs of the cost of food and
the cost of living um in northern
ireland and can start to deal with
reform of our health service which is
urgent particularly post pandemic and
yet at the same time we can negotiate
around how the protocol could be
improved because i think all parties
agree um that certain changes would be
beneficial to northern ireland
businesses
so what do you think needs to change
about the protocol then
well from our perspective we are
pragmatic about the protocol it is
brexit that has ultimately caused the
instability in northern ireland as we
knew it would
the whole purpose of the good friday
agreement was to diminish the importance
of border border issues um and to make
northern ireland function in a fairer
way and unfortunately brexit put borders
and border friction uh back on the
agenda and that is very difficult for
the very delicate ecology of northern
ireland um to deal with
the protocol was an attempt albeit i
would say a rather um a rather heavy
haunted attempt to deal with those
border frictions and to ensure that
there was still free flow across the
border um on the island of ireland and
no hard border established but it did in
the end lead to
an additional level of friction in the
rhc and i understand that for unionists
um that is a very difficult situation
albeit for us it was an inevitability
and a consequence of brexit what we need
to do now is build trust with the
european union we're asking them
essentially um to devolve the protection
of the single market to
to the uk to allow us to have a green
channel for goods coming from gb to
northern ireland that won't go any
further but for them to do that they
need to trust the uk government will do
what it says it's going to do and of
course the history of the protocol is
that they haven't done that they've
taken unilateral action and they've
failed to keep the agreement that they
negotiated and signed so we were very
clear when we met with the prime
minister earlier this week that what we
now need is for
negotiation between the uk and the eu to
be taken seriously by the uk government
for them to live up to the deals that
they make and to work to build trust
rather than take unilateral action which
will undermine that because in doing so
we can minimize the impact of the
protocol on businesses both in gb and in
northern ireland but still allow
northern ireland to have the advantage
that it has which is free and unfettered
access both into the eu single market
for goods and into the uk single market
for goods and we need to exploit that in
order to grow our economy in northern
ireland
i guess what the uk government would
argue is that yes they signed up to the
protocol but they didn't envisage a
situation where the eu would in their
view implement it in a heavy-handed way
so effectively assuming that goods are
going to be going on to the eu rather
than staying in northern ireland do you
have any sympathy with that position
from the uk government
none whatsoever because before they
signed the protocol there is evidence
that was presented to both the prime
minister um and indeed to lord frost
which said i'd very clearly what the
implications of the protocol would be um
you cannot negotiate a daily see what
that deal is going to do sign up to that
deal sell it as a good deal which is how
the prime minister fought the elections
let's remember um and then say that you
didn't fully understand what you'd
signed up to i mean that is just an
admission of failure on behalf of the
government
i think the presumption has always been
that the uk will behave in an
exceptional manner and will be allowed
to do so and unfortunately when we were
part of the european union we set the
rules for third countries and now we are
a third country we need to learn to live
by those rules and it seems to be
something that the government struggles
with i think most people will understand
this is a very simple thing when you
make an agreement and when you give your
word to do something you ought to be at
least prepared to do that thing before
you do so and i think when you don't
people will then trust you less and less
on every subsequent occasion when you're
asked to give your word on something
what we now need is to break that cycle
and actually get the uk government to
deal with the eu who are still despite
everything willing to have these
discussions and willing to try to
accommodate what is in the best
interests of northern ireland and i
think if we can get to a point where the
uk government and the eu can set aside
whatever issues they have build that
trust and get a set of um protocols in
place that will allow good governance
because remember we need for businesses
safe political stability but also
stability in terms of the arrangements
going forward thank you uh very much uh
naomi long there of the alliance party
thank you for being on the program today
and now quick reminder before we go uh
that our weekly cart is available every
week just after lunchtime there'll be
highlights of the interviews and some
thoughts from the team there as well you
can find it wherever you can get your
podcast just search for sophie ridge on
sunday
well that is it for this week sir safety
ridge on sunday another a busy week
could we be seeing sight of the long
awaited sue grey report when we join you
next week it will be interesting to find
out and don't forget of course our
wednesday program 9pm uh on wednesday
night sky news the take at with safety
ridge do tune into that and in the
meantime thank you for joining us and
enjoy the rest of your weekend
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
i'm ivan bonio i'm a sailor
i spent
half time of my life on the on the sea
we have a factory we can convert this
plastic to energy
so after at the end we can minimize the
footprint carbon of the board
[Music]
you